what can you say about the power the
influence of the different intelligence
agencies within their nation and outside
yeah so to answer your question
uh your original question which is the
most powerful i'm gonna have to give you
a few different answers
so
the most powerful intelligence
organization in the world in terms of
reach
is the chinese mss the ministry of state
security because
they have created
a
single solitary intelligence service
that has global reach and is integrated
with chinese culture
so that essentially every chinese person
anywhere in the world is an informant to
the mss because it all that's their way
of serving
this this is the middle kingdom jungwoo
the central kingdom the chinese word for
china
so they're the strongest they're they're
it's the the most powerful intelligence
service in terms of reach most assets
most informants most intelligence is
deeply integrated with a citizenry
correct with their culture you know what
a chinese person who lives in syria
thinks of themselves as a chinese person
do you know what a chinese person a
chinese national living in the united
states thinks of themselves as a chinese
person right americans
living abroad often think of ourselves
as expats expatriates living on the
local economy embracing the local
culture that is not how chinese people
view traveling around the world and by
the way if i may mention
i believe
the way messiah operates
is similar kind of thing because people
from israel
living abroad still think of themselves
as jewish and israeli first
first so that allows you to integrate
the culture and yep the faith-based
aspects exactly right but the number of
people in israel is much much smaller
exactly number one people in china so
when it comes to reach china wins that
game yeah when it comes to professional
capability it's it's the cia
by far because
budget wise capability wise weapon
system wise modern technology wise cia
is the leader around the world which is
why every other intelligence
organization out there wants to partner
with cia
they want to learn from cia they want to
train with cia they want to they want to
partner on counter narcotics and counter
drug and counter terrorism and counter
wieger you name it people want to
partner with cia so cia is the most
powerful in terms of capability and
wealth
and then you've got
the idea you've got
tech
so tech alone
meaning
corporate espionage
economic espionage nothing beats nothing
beats dgse in france they're the top
uh they've got a massive budget that
almost goes exclusively to stealing
foreign secrets they're the biggest
threat to the united states even above
russia and above china dgse in france is
a massively powerful intelligence
organization but they are so exclusively
focused on a handful of types of
intelligence collection that nobody even
really thinks that they exist
and then in terms of
just terrifying violence you have
massage mossad will do anything mossad
has
no qualms doing what it takes to ensure
the survival of every israeli citizen
around the world
most other countries will stop at some
point
but mossad doesn't do that
so it's the lines you're willing to
cross
and the reasons that you're willing to
cross them you know there's
cia will let an american stay in jail in
russia
unlawfully
and seek a diplomatic solution i mean
the united states has let people there
there are two gentlemen in from the
1950s who were imprisoned in china for
20 years waiting for diplomatic
solutions to their release
so
that's it's
we do not kill
to save a citizen
but mossad will
and then they'll not just kill they'll
like do large-scale infiltration
amazing things there is no they they
they spare no expense because it's a
demonstration to their own people again
going back to the whole idea of
influence
every
intelligence operation
that sees the light of day
has two purposes
the first purpose is the intelligence
operation
but if it was just the intelligence
operation it would stay secret forever
the second purpose of every successful
intelligence operation when they become
public is to send a signal to the world
if you work against us we will do this
to you
if you work for us
we will take care of you in this way
it's a massive information campaign
you